(man) The sharks are back
in an all-new season
of "Shark Tank,"
where hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
We have five
pending purchase Orders
for over a million dollars.
If the sharks
hear a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money...
I'm gonna offer you
$200,000.
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
How many brands
have you grown?
Name the brands
that you have grown.
I just passed
a lemonade stand this morning
that sells
more product than you.
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
So you have access
to retailers?
I did $6 billion.
B-B-B-Billion.
It's sink or swim.
I've never seen a man sweat
as much in my life.
(laughter)
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Lori Greiner,
the queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents
and has launched
over 300 products
grossing over a half
a billion dollars
in retail sales.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
who grew his homemade
clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
First in is Aly Lessor,
with a business inspired
by her daughter Cosette.
Hi, sharks.
My name is Aly Lessor,
and I'm the creator
of the children's clothing line
Cozy Bug.
I'm asking for $50,000
in exchange for
25% of my company.
Most kids outgrow their clothes
every season,
and it gets really expensive.
However, our pillowcase dresses
grow with the kids.
And the way
they're designed,
they cinch here
at the neck,
and then we use
these beautiful ribbons
that tie at the shoulder,
allowing for growth
under the arm
and in length.
Now eventually,
the kids sprout so much,
and then you just put on
an adorable pair
of leggings or shorts
and you have another outfit
for years to come.
Cosette is 4 years old,
and she's in
a size 4.
This is Morgan,
who's 8 years old,
and she is still
in a size 4.
I'm a Southern girl
now living in Los Angeles,
and my mother-In-law
in Alabama
started mailing us
the most adorable
monogrammed pillowcase
dresses
for my daughter Cosette.
Cosette is Cozy Bug.
That's her nickname.
And whenever she wore them,
we would literally get stopped
four to five times a day
by moms saying,
"Where did you get
that outfit?"
and that's when I decided
to pillowcase the world.
Our pillowcase dresses are not
actually made from pillowcases.
We use really fun,
vibrant fabrics.
We have jackets, jeggings,
shirts,
and of course every outfit
needs a matching hair bow,
which we've sold
thousands of.
I have taken Cozy Bug
just about as far as I can
with my contacts.
With your help
and expertise,
we can make Cozy Bug
an international brand
and take it places
I could only imagine.
So come on, sharks.
Who's ready to pillowcase
the world?
Aw!
(sharks laugh)
Okay, thank you, girls.
Say bye to the sharks.
Bye, sharks!
(Lori) Bye!
(Mark) See ya!
(men) Bye!
Aw. (laughs)
I'm in.
(laughter)
(laughs)
Is the concept
of a pillowcase dress
something that's been around
in the south forever,
as you said?
It has, yes.
(Lori) Oh, really?
Yeah.
How many people
are in your company?
Me.
Just you?
Yeah.
(Robert)
What's your background?
I was in sales. I've been
in sales for 20 years.
And had my daughter Cosette.
And they were not letting me
pump my breast milk at work.
And I told my 26-year-old
female manager,
"I need to pump,"
and she's like,
"Oh, we don't have time
for that right now.
You're gonna have to wait."
So I told my manager,
"I'm sorry.
I have to go do this
right now."
And she's like, "you can get
your stuff and go home."
Fired me--
Oh, my--
Wow.
Really?
Yes. And, uh...
come on.
Yes, so I sued her, won,
and I had money
to start my company.
Wow, good for you.
I love that.
Outstanding. Great story.
I can't believe somebody
would say that to you. That's--
I was like,
what year are we in?
A female, at that.
What does it cost you
to make one pillowcase dress?
$6.
With fabric
and manufacturing.
I know you guys could get
that done a lot cheaper.
(chuckles)
Where are you selling?
The main place we sell
is online.
In just 30 days,
we sold over $300,000...
Whoa. Oh.
Worth of dresses.
Oh. Really?
The Web site that I sell on--
Have you guys heard of
zulily?
So you're allowed
to go on there
three days every month.
And within 30 days
of being on there,
$300,000.
Ooh!
We also just launched
our own dancewear line
called Dance Bug.
We sell tutus and all that.
(Kevin) Why,
when you know you've found
this remarkable niche,
would you want to bother
competing
with everybody else
in the children's lines,
making, you know,
ballerina dresses and coats?
Kevin's right.
So you think just this?
You've got--You've got
the ability
to differentiate yourself
from everybody,
and it's making you
a boatload of money.
Why not be great
at one thing?
I don't agree with that,
because this is
a fashion item--
'cause it doesn't work
on QVC, that's why.
If mark knew about fashion,
he would know that women,
when you start with something
and it's a great concept
and people are loving it,
they want more.
And that's how businesses
continue to grow
and grow and grow.
So you are very smart to--
That's also how businesses
go out of business as well.
They try to get too wide--
All of these--
Nothing great.
Well, maybe,
But not in fashion, Mark.
In fashion--
Right, because so many fashion
companies just stay in business.
They all stay in business.
None of them ever go out
from expanding their lines
too quickly.
But, Mark, you're not
in the fashion business.
Okay, Aly, here--Here's
the way I see it.
The biggest mistake many,
many entrepreneurs make
is that they try to do
too much too soon.
And it kills them
and they go out of business.
I like to shoot for the stars.
I see me going everywhere.
I'm glad you told me that,
because to me,
it's better to dominate
at one thing
and then build off of that.
By going too wide,
typically companies drown.
And so, for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Thank you.
I'm not here
just for money.
I'm here for a partnership.
I have tried countless times
to even get phone numbers
or contacts of the buyers
at the big box stores.
It's impossible.
It's a secret society.
All right, let me--
Let me clear
the field a little bit.
I can't really offer you
the expertise
in terms of what you're doing
and your expansion plans.
Let me get out of the way.
I'm out.
I wish you all the best.
And I'll make you
an offer, okay?
Because you're unique.
I'll give you $50,000,
and here's how much equity
I want in your business.
Zero. Okay?
You're gonna pay me
$2 a dress
until I get my 50k back,
and then you're gonna pay me
$1 forever after that.
Here's the covenant.
I forbid you to make anything
except hair bows
and pillowcase dresses.
Every dress does need
a hair bow. (laughs)
(laughter)
It's true.
Last season,
I took a woman
who came in with a towel
with a slit in it.
Mr. Wonderful said
It was insane.
It was madness.
And to date, we're
in the Disney theme parks,
all over, with that towel
with the slit in it.
I'm going to offer you
the $50,000...
Take 30% stake in the company,
and take this nationwide.
And not just on QVC,
but we can take it
into all the retailers,
and I think that I can
make you a millionaire
with this line.
Here's why that's
a bad idea.
If you go the route
that Lori's suggesting,
you don't make enough money
to sell to retailers--
Excuse me.
Silence.
You're the silent partner.
Here's what's--
Here's what's good about
what I'm doing for you.
I am forcing you into
a tunnel of profitability,
where every time you get up
in the morning and make a sale,
you make money.
That's a grand plan,
kind of like the "titanic."
And that is the only plan.
(Daymond)
Let me just, uh...
don't even get involved.
I'm just gonna take
the deal. Um...
(laughs)
This is my area.
I know I can make you
the millionaire quicker.
I'm gonna offer you
the $50,000 for 30%--
The same thing as Lori's.
And your avenue would be to
get it in the retail stores?
That's the only value
that I would bring to it,
is to roll it out to retail,
to roll it out quick,
to roll it out globally,
and bring you into my system
and distribute it.
(Lori) And I can do
all of the above...
(Kevin) Aly, these--
Just the same and more.
(Kevin speaks Indistinctly)
Wait a minute, wait.
Stop, stop, stop.
I have to clarify one thing,
because if you go with her,
right after she sells
hemorrhoid cream,
she'll sell your stuff and then
dental cream or something else.
We are not all--
Who knows what he's
even talking about?
We are not all--listen.
I know how to do
what you want to be done.
Daymond, I just passed
a lemonade stand this morning
that sells more product
than you.
Whoa! (laughs)
Ow.
I know.
I did $6 billion.
B-B-B-Billion.
I did $500 million
with walmart This year.
You're selling dresses
for little girls.
Who do you think
is a better partner
to make clothing
for little girls?
(Daymond) I have
two daughters.
I did $1 billion
in kids' clothing alone.
Would you guys,
Lori and Daymond,
ever want to do
a sweetheart deal,
where we all work together?
No.
I don't want it on QVC.
Okay. Okay.
I do not want it on QVC...
okay.
And I don't think you should
have it on QVC.
Okay.
You gotta start making
some decisions.
So what are you gonna do?
♪♪♪
Aly has three offers
on the table.
Kevin's offer--
$50,000 for zero equity,
but a royalty
for every dress sold.
And competing offers
from Lori and Daymond,
each offering $50,000
for 30% equity.
All roads lead to Mr. Wonderful.
(laughs)
(mark laughs)
One question for Lori.
Um, so you plan to do QVC
and you have
access to retailers?
I have ins
to all the retailers,
all across America.
And, Daymond, you just have
the contacts everywhere.
I know you do.
I have a full global
distribution center.
I have 15 designers
that work for me.
Okay. And you don't see it
at all being a problem
to get in Macy's or Penney's
or wherever you see?
I don't see it being a problem.
And I'm already doing
heavy volume
and heavy business
with all of them.
I don't want to do it, aly...
Lori, listen--
I'm gonna tell you something
right now. Lori, listen.
But I'm going to pull out
a check...
Lori--Lori, listen. Lori--
And write you a check
right now.
If she writes you a check,
I'm not gonna match it.
You know what?
I believe in you so much...
Lori, how many brands
have you made? Not products.
That I just wrote a check
on the spot.
How many brands
have you grown?
(Mark) Aly--Aly--
I'm not listening to him.
Lori, how many brands
have you grown?
Aly, I'm talking to you.
Name the brand
that you have grown.
I'm not gonna sit here
and name--
Aly--Aly--
There's many deals I did...
having said--
Just last year
on "Shark Tank,"
okay? And it's not--
Okay, guys, guys, that's--
That's enough.
This is what they do--
Aly, tell them to stop.
Do you have any other
questions?
Aly, this is what they do
when they're threatened.
Aly, what are you
going to do?
Well...
Who do you want
as a partner?
Right this way.
That's really the bottom line.
Who do you want as a partner?
Aly, what are you
going to do?
Who do you feel will be
the best partner?
I am going to...
(clicks tongue) Oh, man.
If you're not sure
of who to go with,
I may take away my offer,
because I feel you should know
what's the right offer.
(clicks tongue)
Okay, Daymond,
we have a deal.
Good decision.
(Mark) congratulations.
Okay, thank you.
All right.
(Robert) boy, I did--
Give me a hug.
I did not see that one
coming.
I gotta know why. Why?
I just didn't like
the "take away"...
what do you mean?
That Lori offered me.
She's like, "I'm gonna
take my deal away,"
and I was like,
"Ohh! Daymond!"
good decision.
Congratulations.
Thank you, guys.
I really wanted Lori
and Daymond,
and it was very chaotic,
very hectic.
In my brain, I was like,
"Oh, my god, what do I do?"
but I'm so excited
I chose Daymond,
and now we're gonna
pillowcase the world.
Every time Lori tries
to make a deal,
you guys dump on her
for the QVC.
You see when it's a tech play,
I go to you three guys.
We can handle it.
You see when it's a QVC play,
I ask about Lori.
When she gets in my space...
I hear you--
Come on!
You just do that
because you're threatened.
But when did Lori say she was
gonna put her on QVC?
At the beginning.
She always says it!
Listen, both of you,
suck it up.
Be a shark
and stop your whining.
It's ridiculous.
(laughter)
Oh...
On season 2, brothers
David and Stu Pikoff
Turned down an offer
from Kevin O'Leary
for 51% of games2u,
which brings
games and entertainment
to children's parties
and events.
A controlling position
in our company
is not something we're
able or willing to do.
Let's see what they're
up to now.
♪♪♪
You know, the "Shark Tank"
effect was amazing for us.
Since being on "Shark Tank,"
our business
has absolutely exploded.
(man) Hey, Dave,
how's it going down there?
Man, it's going great.
The contract just came in
from the great white north.
We got all kinds
of international interest,
and now we're in
seven different countries.
We have 165 locations
under development
in Canada alone, plus six
countries in the middle east.
We went from over
$4 million a year
to now over $9 million
a year.
And games2U is tracking
to double again This year.
We're pointing toward
$20 million in Sales.
♪♪♪
Hey, guys, it's games2u!
(cheering)
The credibility from
being on "Shark Tank"
is something that'll live on
for years to come.
But in addition to that, it's
such a great source of pride.
It's a concept we came up with
five years ago,
and now to see thousands
of kids Across America
enjoying our stuff
every day is really neat for us.
♪♪♪
Next into the tank
is Roger Sullivan
with an eye-opening
new product.
♪♪♪
Hi. My name's Roger Sullivan.
My company is Wired Waffles.
I'm here seeking $75,000
for a 25% stake
in the company.
Basically, we've taken
an energy drink
and we've put it
into a waffle.
Think about it--People
walk into a convenience store,
and they grab an energy drink
or a shot for their energy,
But they still need a snack
to satisfy their hunger.
The wired waffle does both.
With our proprietary
energy blend,
we've been able to create
something that's delicious,
functional, and designed for
today's most active lifestyles.
And I've brought some samples
for you guys to try.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you, sir.
There you go.
♪♪♪
So who wants to shake on a deal
and make some money?
Can I see the packaging?
Absolutely.
I want to see
the ingredients.
Roger, do you put anything
on it to make it taste better?
Thank you.
Um, you can,
But the--they were designed
with the flavor already
inside of them.
They taste really dry.
Is that part of the flavor?
Yeah. It's, um...
they were designed to be
more like a scone texture,
so something that, uh, is--
is kind of complementary to--
What is the shelf life
of this?
It lasts for 30 days
on the shelf.
This has guarana in it,
or no?
No, it does not. It has
natural caffeine extract.
How much caffeine is in this?
Is this like drinking
five cups of coffee?
It's about a 20-ounce
premium cup of coffee.
Venti.
So it's really like four
or five cups of coffee?
I mean, regular cups--
It's about three.
Like, really?
So, if I--
if I ate two of these,
what would happen?
You'd just be--
You'd just be excited.
Basically what I did is
I looked at--I looked at--
Just be excited.
It would take many more than
that to get him excited.
How long have you been
selling these?
Where have you been
Give us some background.
Okay, Well, um,
we first brought
the product to market
back in October, um, for...
we did a-a test run
of about 10,000 units.
Based on the feedback
that we got during that time,
we went back
to the drawing board,
we changed the recipe,
and then
we've officially launched
This particular product
less than a month ago.
What are sales, then?
Can you give us
any indication
in the first month
what you sold?
Um, the first month,
right now,
we're at about--
We're at about $1,000.
Oh, really?
$1,000.
I just got--
I got, um...
you of course realize
that is absolutely nothing?
Absolutely. Absolutely.
Give him a chance.
He just got started.
Yeah, absolutely.
So $1,000--He's Only
sold it for a month.
But on Friday, I got a phone
call from one of our brokers,
and he's telling me that
he's putting together an order
that's 22 pallets. It could be
a $140,000 order.
(Kevin) Who's buying that?
A distributor
in Dallas, Texas.
And have they
ever tried it before?
Actually, they have
sampled the product.
They actually move
another waffle product
in convenience stores,
and they're thinking
they can put ours
right alongside of it,
and that it'll take off.
Roger, let's assume
it takes off.
What stops any
confectionary operator
that has massive distribution
from absolutely killing you
by doing this themselves?
There's nothing
proprietary about this.
No, there--There--
There's not.
But, you know,
the thing is,
is we've--We've taken
and we've energized
one of the most
recognizable comfort foods
on the face of the planet.
People love waffles.
So if someone's
gonna come along,
they're either
gonna have to just be
a blatant,
outright copy, or--
Yeah? So?
You have to admit,
you have an idea.
If this concept takes hold
and gets traction,
you are the pioneer that'll get
the arrows in his back,
because any large
confectionary operator
with, you know,
industrial kitchens
will slaughter you
like the cockroach you are.
You know what? You say--
How do you stop that
from happening?
You say that to...
you know, seriously,
I am so...
You know why? It's true.
I am so sick of that...
Yay, Robert.
Tell it like it is.
Line from you.
You know what?
You say that to everybody.
Every--"you're not unique.
You don't have a patent."
I want to know the answer.
Are you telling me everything
you've ever invested in,
it was the only one out there?
I want a proprietary
fence around it,
so it has a chance!
You're such an idiot!
You want--Kevin, you know why
you want a proprietary fence?
Why not?
Because you don't know how
to run a company,
you don't know how
to preempt the competition...
sure I do.
You don't know how to compete,
you don't know how to sell.
You don't know
how to create profit.
Did all that already.
You want--You want
it all handed to you.
No.
That's just wrong.
I want to make
smart investments,
not stupid ones, Mark.
I'm thinking about
giving you the money
because it gave us
the energy to argue.
(laughter)
How do you stop children
from buying these?
No kidding.
Because they would just be,
like, crazed, wouldn't they?
There's a warning
on the label, you know,
that says that it's
not intended for kids.
It's not intended for,
you know, pregnant mothers.
We're targeting
the same market
that's going after
the energy drinks.
Now I'd like to
stand here and say,
you know, that
we're--We're going after
the 18-
to 35-year-old market.
But the fact is, is that
kids drink energy drinks.
You know, my kids
Drink energy drinks.
The neighbor kids
drink energy drinks.
But, you know,
that's where Lori's right--
Someone's gonna
crush you,
crush you
on the selling it to kids.
I do think it's a bit
of a liability nightmare.
That's a lot of caffeine,
and it's a sweet.
So kids are gonna
get their hands on it,
and I think
that's very problematic.
For that reason,
I'm out.
I don't really know people
that eat cold waffles.
Is that something that...
the product
was designed originally to--
It's best heated up.
But because we're going after
the convenience store market,
where we're displaying,
where point of sale is,
stuff is right on the counter,
it's by the coffee stuff,
it's by the microwave.
But you don't
say that on here.
You don't recommend
it be heated up.
I don't get the product.
I think
that the whole purpose
energy shots are working
is it's quick.
You take it, you're gone.
This is becoming a process
of making a meal almost.
Um, so I wish you luck,
but I'm out.
Look, Roger,
I like the idea
you created
a new category...
Mm-hmm.
For caffeine
energy products.
I just--I just don't see
a waffle as the one
that's gonna open
a market share.
And for $75,000,
I don't wanna bet
on waffles.
I'm out.
We've got, you know,
I-I-I don't know what else
to say. You know--
Roger, it's actually--
It's actually a good idea.
I can--I can envision it
being in convenience stores,
and to pick up,
and, you know,
I can see somebody
saying, "Oh," you know,
"peanut butter
and chocolate," you know?
Energy drinks and waffles.
But I don't see you
selling a lot of them.
And--
Here's--Here's
the deal, mark--
is basically, I've created
the energy blend
that I can put into anything.
I put it into a waffle
because we felt like
we were looking
for a breakfast snack,
a breakfast offering, okay?
I get it. I get that.
The bad news is, I-I-I just
didn't like the product.
And so for that reason,
I'm out.
All right. Thanks.
Caffeine is the most
consumed drug in the world.
And that goes to my point.
You know,
here's the frustration--
If you had stood there
and said to me,
look, I've found a unique
and proprietary way
to infuse baked goods with
the most popular drug on earth,
and my plan is to go
to license it
to a thousand bakeries that make
food that people already eat,
and brands they already know,
that's a business
I would invest in.
It's a proprietary
energy blend that I've created
to be able
to put into anything.
Yes, but that's not
your business plan.
You want to actually
establish distribution
of a waffle that so far, not one
shark said they liked eating.
That's the cold,
hard truth about this.
It doesn't taste
that good.
I'm out.
Thanks, Kevin.
All right. Thanks, guys.
Good luck, Roger.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate your time.
Thank you.
Obviously, I'm disappointed.
But at the end of the day,
the success of our business
doesn't--doesn't rest
on the shoulders of five people.
♪♪♪
(bell clangs, whistle blows)
My name's Cheryl Rigdon.
I live
in Easley, South Carolina,
with my husband Michael
and our two dogs,
Tyson and Sierra.
Tyson! Bring that Frisbee!
Come here!
Sie--No. Don't lay down.
Come here.
You could definitely say
I'm a small-town Southern girl.
I came up with
my product idea
when I was
putting on makeup
to go out with my husband
for dinner.
I was getting so frustrated
with all the makeup
I was wasting,
having to throw away
because I couldn't get
to the bottom of my bottle.
So I looked online
for a product to buy,
and there wasn't
anything there.
So I just decided
to make it myself.
My idea's really simple,
But everyone says
that the best ideas
are the simple ones.
I know I have a great idea
that everyone would want.
But I've never started
a business before,
so I really need
the sharks' help.
With one of the sharks
behind me,
we could have my product
in every home in America.
♪♪♪
Hello. My name is
Cheryl Rigdon,
and I'm the creator
of the Spatty.
I am asking for $50,000
for 40% of my business.
The Spatty is
a money-saving tool
that is gonna be in the homes
of people around the world.
As you all know, everyone's
talking about the economy
and how to stretch a dollar.
Take this bottle of lotion
as an example.
You can see there's still
lots of product
left at the bottom.
But you try to get it out
and nothing comes out.
So you look around the house
for something to use.
You try a spoon.
It's not gonna
fit in there, obviously.
You know, you try
a spatula.
You know,
just the hole's too small.
Nothing's gonna
fit in there.
So you just have to throw
all that product in the trash.
Well, I have a product
that is gonna end
all the unnecessary waste.
So let me introduce y'all
to the revolutionary...
Spatty...
(laughs)
And Spatty Daddy.
Whoa.
(sharks laugh)
Spatty Daddy!
Kevin, you have your new name!
The Spatty Daddy.
(laughs)
the Spatty and Spatty Daddy
are simple,
versatile tools...
(laughter)
(laughs)
They're, um,
simple, versatile tools
that fit inside
small openings
and will pay for themselves
in the first week they are used.
The Spatty and Spatty Daddy
give the consumer...
(laughs)
the ability to get every last
drop of their products
and will save the consumer
a significant amount of money.
Spatty and Spatty Daddy
work on many items.
Your makeups,
your face creams,
your shampoos,
your conditioners.
They're simple
But brilliant tools.
I'm gonna let y'all
try out a Spatty
and a Spatty Daddy
on some products.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
All right. I'll take
the little Spatty,
and the little bottle.
I figured you'd be
the little Spatty.
No, no, I wanna test
the surgical precision.
Where's your accent from?
From Greenville,
South Carolina.
Oh, it's a great accent.
Thanks.
I love your accent.
I do. I love it, though.
I do, too.
Thank you.
So what you do,
you just put it in,
and you just, um,
move it along the sides.
Um, and you can see
how much comes off.
Um, there's actually
a study done
by "Consumer Reports"
that shows you throw away
17% to 25% of the product.
Um, let's say this is
a $60 bottle of makeup,
that's $15.
Cheryl, who makes them?
Who physically makes them?
I do.
Right now,
they're just prototypes.
So that's why I'm asking
for the money,
so I can get
these manufactured.
Do you have a plan, Cheryl,
on how you're gonna sell these?
Well, first, I gotta
get 'em manufactured
and get 'em packaged.
Let's assume we've got
all that solved.
I have to...
Oh, you're--You're not
selling any at all today?
I put a couple on ebay,
just to see
how they would sell,
and get unbiased
opinions on 'em.
And kind of see
what price range
people would pay for it.
And what happened?
I had about 15
that sold off ebay.
Everybody really liked 'em.
They said,
"This is a great product.
It works perfectly."
And what price did you
sell it to them for?
Um, $2.99 for the Spatty,
$3.99 for the Spatty Daddy.
How much is it gonna cost you
before you can
start selling them?
I called a place in Florida,
and they said it would cost
a little over $9,000
for the molds
for the Spatty Daddy,
a little over $7,000
for the molds for the Spatty.
Is there any way,
do you think,
that you can test the market?
'cause 15 people
on ebay...
is not a lot. Yeah.
No, it's not.
This stuff is sheer gold.
Yes.
So if you can actually get
17% more out of a...
of makeup...
But will you still get
17% more out?
Or will you just--Because
it doesn't get everything.
You're still
gonna have--
It does if you keep--Look.
It does if you keep going.
I mean, if you really cared
about whatever this is,
you could get 90% of
what's in here with the Spatty.
I get it.
I think some people
would use it.
(Lori) Some people would.
(Robert) So, Cheryl,
you get the money,
you get them made...
What happens next?
How are you
gonna sell these?
I think QVC would be
a great way to go.
Um, I think
that Mary Kay and Avon,
they have a lot of people
out in the fields
around the world
who sell their makeup.
And they have to
test it out on people.
Cheryl, the problem
with that strategy
is it increases
the packaging costs...
Yeah.
For a consumer goods
company.
Okay.
I think the challenge
with this idea
is how do you get it
into the hands
of all the consumers
that can make use of it?
There's a cost
to doing that.
Yeah.
That is where the risk
in this deal is.
You've got a really
interesting product
and a great idea,
but what you haven't
brought me is the plan
on how you're gonna get it
into 100 million households.
And so for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
Well, yeah, Kevin is
somewhat right.
I mean, he's never
all the way right.
He's always right.
In that it's a product,
it's not a company yet.
And you know that, right?
And that's why you're here
looking for help.
Yeah.
The challenge is formulating
an entire company.
And all the time and resources
required to do that.
And I just don't have
that time.
Um, so for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Cheryl, Mark and Kevin
are partly right.
But you never know.
Spatty Daddy
could be brilliant,
or Spatty Daddy could be dead.
The difference is gonna be
in you
and how you take it
to the market.
I'm a very, um,
goal-Oriented, um, person.
I don't even like
downtime.
I'm really bad.
It drives my husband crazy,
but I can't just
go home and sit.
I have to be doing something.
Cheryl, I have
no doubt about you.
Yeah.
I have some doubts about
Spatty Daddy as a business.
Okay.
I'm out.
I don't have the finances
to make it go any further
than where it is now.
And that's where
I really need y'all
to help me out with that.
And I promise y'all
that I will work
night and day
on this if need be.
I think we're all
in love with you,
but it's just
a little too early for us.
I'm sorry. I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
I think, you know, this product
would sell tremendously
on QVC.
Well, you know,
I love you,
and I love your drive
and your determination.
And I love that you thought
and created something.
You had a problem,
you came up with the solution.
But I think it's too inexpensive
of a price point for QVC,
because people already have
to pay $5, $6...
for shipping and handling.
Shipping and handling.
And, uh, I see it as something
that could be
a promotional item,
that you could present
to avon or other places
how would
you contact them?
Like, if I just call them up,
would they talk to me?
Or would they say,
you know...
well, I would find
somebody in your area
that's an avon distributor,
and talk to them,
and say, "who's the head
of this region?"
I think you'll go far
because of you,
and because of your drive.
I'm sorry. For me,
I don't think it's the right
product right now.
I do think
it's more promotional.
And so for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
Good luck.
So thank y'all
for y'all's time.
Good luck. You know
what I'm gonna do?
I'm gonna give you
the number
to two of
the big makeup people...
Oh, that'd be great.
And I'll let you
contact them, okay?
Thank you.
That'd be awesome.
Thank you so much.
No problem. Good luck.
All right. Thank you.
All right. Bye.
Thank y'all.
Bye.
The sharks gave me
some great advice in the tank,
and I hope they smile
when they see the Spatty
and the Spatty Daddy
on the shelf.
♪♪♪
Next up are
Brandon and Keith Marz,
with a product designed
to make it easier
to be health-conscious.
Hello. My name
is Brandon Marz,
this is my dad Keith,
and our company
is Marz Sprays.
We're seeking $200,000
for a 10% equity interest
in our company.
We're here today to talk
about something
that nobody likes to do,
and that's swallow pills.
We all like
the benefits we get
from vitamins
and supplements.
But did you know
that over 100 million people
in the United States Alone
cannot or have difficulty
swallowing pills?
What's worse,
they might not even work.
If you took a vitamin b
or a vitamin c pill
That may look like
it's the size of Pittsburgh,
you may only absorb
10% or 20% of it.
As a father of two boys
who refused to swallow
any pills,
I knew something
had to be done.
So we developed
Marz Sprays--
a full line of oral sprays
for health and wellness.
C-Spray is our multivitamin
immunity blend,
which has as much
Vitamin c
as 114 oranges.
Kids spray has
the real nutrients
from all these real
fruits and vegetables.
Slim spray was developed
with the assistance
of doctors and phds
to help reduce
food cravings.
Reboot is our energy spray,
which has a megadose
of vitamin b-12.
If you bought 1 energy shot
each day for 30 days,
you'd spend over $100.
Reboot retails for $14.99,
and lasts an entire month.
Sleep spray has three well-Known
sleep aid ingredients--
Gaba, melatonin,
and valerian root.
I'll try the reboot.
I want the reboot, too.
Hit me.
No problem.
And can I look at the c-Spray?
Sure.
Give her the sleep spray.
(laughs)
(Mark) Please.
Thank you, Brandon.
My pleasure.
Spray it
in your mouth.
(spritzes)
Wow. That's really strong.
Whoo! (coughs) Oh!
Reboot.
Reboot for you?
Lot of energy takers
in the crowd.
(spritzing)
It's got an awful taste.
Chocolate?
It's chocolate.
Yeah.
It's chocolate. That's 'cause
you don't like sweets.
We also have created
and paid for and developed
five infomercials.
In fact,
I could show you one.
I have it on my phone.
Since I have
a t-Mobile phone,
I can just share it
on that tv.
Vitamin c.
(laughs) You know it's good
for supporting
your immune system.
If you've taken
vitamin C pills or powders
for any of these benefits,
then get ready,
because the next evolution
of vitamin c is here,
and it's as simple
as spray... Spray.
C-Spray daily
immune system support.
Hmm.
Not bad.
Very good.
It's Nicely done.
Thank you.
So why do you feel
that this is a solution
to the people
that have to take pills?
For the 100
to 150 million people
that can't swallow pills...
and where did you get
this data from?
'cause you're saying
almost half of America...
40%.
Will not take pills.
That was a study done
by a company called
Harris interactive.
But you realize how stupid
it all sounds, right?
You're saying that everybody
who delivers anything via pill
is so stupid
they can't figure out
that there's this big market...
Oh, no, no, no.
For alternative
deliveries.
They're not stupid.
They have a market share
that's fine with them.
There's lots of companies
offering homeopathic
alternatives using sprays.
There's
no major market Leader.
We're poised
to be that Leader.
So you're saying...
Well, Wait, wait, wait.
What about vitamins?
There's so many--
Wait, wait, wait.
You're saying
there's so many competitors,
that none of them
has really taken the lead,
and you wanna compete
with all of them?
No. We're saying--
But wait, Mark...
Mark, I think you took
a different spray than I did.
You seem very irritable
about this.
It's a scam!
I mean, it's a hustle, right?
I mean, it's a hustle.
Wait a second.
The whole supplement market's
a hustle.
Exactly.
Hey, Yeah, Keith,
he just called you a hustler.
Now hold it, Keith.
I know, and I was
offended by that,
because--
Guys. Guys.
Your answer is simple--
The supplement market is
a multibillion-dollar market.
So why don't you
just say that?
Do I have to say that for you?
What's the matter with you guys?
Brandon, holy crap!
What did you give us
in this?
Wait a minute. Wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Let's all stop.
Lots of b-12.
It's very good for you.
Trust me.
They're feeling like
chum in the water.
It works.
To answer your question,
we're not hustlers.
We have first mover advantage.
But, Brandon,
prove us wrong.
Do you have any sales?
Yes.
So originally, we only
had one product,
which was
the slim spray product,
and we sold that
in some small retail locations
and to one distributor.
Give me a number!
You need to hear
the story.
I'm jacked up on b-12! Hit me.
He's--he's--he's gonna
give you an answer.
In about nine months,
we did about $125,000
of sales.
What are your total sales,
all products?
Keep in mind these products,
as you see them
packaged here today,
entered into
our fulfillment center
nine business days ago.
We attended and exhibited
at the largest
vitamin supplement conference
in the world.
The response
was absolutely overwhelming.
One of the first people
that asked for an appointment
was one of the biggest pill
companies in the United States.
What company?
Nature's--Nature's made.
Nature's made.
Now that's interesting.
So they're interested?
We're negotiating a licensing
agreement with them right now.
They want--
and--and that's the answer
to mark's question.
They want to do
a licensing agreement.
Now why is that?
Because they have
144 different S.K.U.S
so they don't need
to be in our business.
But, Keith, hang on a sec.
I know you didn't invent
the ability to spray...
absolutely not.
Right.
So what do they want
from you?
They specifically came
to us and said,
"we don't have the capacity
to make an oral spray.
You've done a great job doing
it. We want to license it."
We also have
five pending purchase Orders
for over a million dollars.
Whoa.
Why are they pending?
What's the pending?
The reason they're pending--and
that's a very valid question.
It's a good question.
We went to
an international conference
where buyers came
from all over the world.
The only reason
it's pending...
it's europe.
They have to clear it.
Is because we haven't
registered our product...
they have to clear it.
Yes.
In their
respective countries.
We've hired a consultant
out of France
that's right now
registering our products
in the seven countries that we
have interest from originally.
You know, registering
each one of those countries
takes a long period
of time.
It's like every version
of the F.D.A.,
and it make take
six months, a year.
There's gonna be
a lot of challenges
with claims, labels,
international shipping.
A lot
of those other countries
are way more stringent
than we are.
We've been quoted 60 to 90 days
for the full registration
process.
I know it'll take longer because
I've--I've dealt in this.
I'm out.
I-I will tell you this--
The reboot stuff
really works.
I'm hyper enough.
Look at him.
Um, I'm not
a big supplement guy.
I never gave external
vitamins to my kids.
I think there's way too much
of that going on in society.
I find the whole thing
hard to swallow.
I'm out.
I'm not a big believer
that you have anything
that's protectable.
I think you've vastly
underestimated
How much money
it's gonna take
to become "the brand."
I don't think
it has to be protected
for us to be the Leader
in this industry.
I'm out.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Lori, together, we can
make a lot of money.
Well, here's the thing.
I like what you're doing,
so I'm gonna
make you an offer.
♪♪♪
Three sharks are out.
Kevin and Lori are
Brandon and Keith's last chance
to make a deal.
Well, here's the thing.
I like what you're doing.
I'm into
the vitamin industry.
I like
the homeopathic industry.
I believe in both.
And I like the fact
that this is an oral spray.
So I'm gonna
make you an offer.
I'm gonna offer you $200,000,
but I want 30% of the company
contingent upon you getting
the nature's made deal.
Thank you very much
for the offer.
I think there's one more,
just in fairness,
that we're waiting for,
and that's you,
Mr. Wonderful.
Hmm. Interesting.
I also like this space
because of its size.
I like what Lori
brings to the table,
and we don't--We don't
participate together very often,
but I love
her leverage on tv.
Why does she need you?
But--Wait.
Silence, please.
I say we give 'em
$250,000 for 40%.
I'd rather do it alone.
Well, because I threw her
an Olive leaf,
and she stepped on it...
she did.
I am forced to do this--
I will give you
the $200,000 for 25%.
Do not screw
with Mr. Wonderful.
Guys, two deals on the table.
Mr. Wonderful--
$200,000 for 25%.
Lori--$200,000 for 30%.
I've never seen a man sweat
as much in my life.
(laughter)
I will match Kevin's deal.
Wow!
Is this not a moment
where you thank Mr. Wonderful?
Without his bid...
the undertaker.
You would have had somebody
take an extra 5%.
You should give that to me
for free.
Lori, can I ask you a question?
I'm in this for the equity.
Would you give me
a redemption option
to buy back half the stock
at three times your investment?
You keep half.
That way we both can get
very rich together.
You believe in it so much?
Then buy it back at four times.
Kevin, did you hear
our proposal to Lori?
I never participate
in options
where I am not getting
any upside.
This is an equity deal.
We're partners together.
It's unfair
for one partner to say,
"listen, after all
the risks have been taken,
"and things are on fire,
and it's working,
I call back my equity."
But remember--
The original deal was for 10%.
So the difference was something
that you threw out there.
You're gonna lose
both deals in a second.
Lori, we came here wanting
to be partners with you.
There's no question
you are gonna bring
this product to America.
One last shot--Will you
consider 20%,
same deal,
and we have a deal?
We buy back half,
20%, $200,000.
What--
No.
Okay. 25% is your deal?
You got a deal, Lori.
Great.
Whoo!
All right.
This is gonna be great.
We're very excited
to be partners.
I gotta tell you,
I did not see that
ending up the way it did.
Congratulations.
Thanks so much.
You got hustled, Lori.
(laughs) I did not get hustled.
The buyback...
is bad.
The buyback was ridiculous.
No. She didn't agree
to the buyback.
Yes, she did.
You agreed
to the buyback?
Four times. Four times.
Lori, he out-sharked you
on that one.
That's his company--
No, he didn't.
That's his company,
and he has the right to have
the major stake in it.
After you've taken
all the risk?
It--It--
Help make us popular,
and then get out of here?
You guys, this is the decision
that I made.
I made it for my reasons,
and I think
it was the right decision.
You cost us a fortune.
I did what
I thought was right,
and--And I feel good about it.
Whew!